(upbeat music)
- I have this beautiful
daughter named Jett,
she's amazing, she likes
pizza, she likes ninjas,
and she likes dresses,
which makes me feel awesome
'cause she's a princess,
but she's also a ninja
that likes to chase zombies.
And I'm like, I'm doing
a great job as a dad.
(audience laughs)
So, I instantly began to wonder
what her dreams would be,
and I thought to myself,
how can I tell her that
she can be anything
and everything in the
world that she wanted to be
if I don't go out and be
everything that I ever wanted to be
in the world?
I grew up wanted to be
Michael Jordan and Dr. Seuss,
Larry Bird and Professor Dumbledore,
Deion Sanders and Willy Wonka.
So, I started a little company
called The Imagination Agency.
Around the same time, I began
to read books to my daughter.
I read hundreds, and
hundreds of children's books,
'til one day I realized
none of those characters
looked like my daughter.
So, I thought, if I don't
make black characters,
then who would?
And I wanted to make a character
that looked like my daughter Jett,
so what better than a
character that was her,
that looked exactly like her,
and it was named after her?
So, therefore, Hey AJ! was born.
Hey AJ! was my first children's
book that I released.
Since then, I've written books,
I released my first
animated short film, Zoovie,
I got interactive children's
book apps, I make games,
so look at me as like your travel agent.
(audience laughs)
Anytime you wanna go to a great adventure,
you come to me at The Imagination Agency
and we will take you on that.
What do you wanna be when you grow up?
You can be anything, the
world is your playground,
let's play.